now let's talk about let's say he does
not need tricksters I've never seen his
breathtaking a girl of my life and her
smile is so genuine balloon are you
doing this Aria what you could have seen
the look norm gave me as you were
hugging me as like him he looked at me
like it
you're a creep you're an old codger you
are a fair old man no no no you are a
scallion you know I may be a scapegrace
but in this case I'm absolutely genuine
I don't mean every word of what I said
is true a little bit like where Donnie
you met Marlo even I don't get that
you guys go way back yes go way back to
juvie axon BP yes I was I did a guest
work on her old show yeah that is so
awesome
yeah I've been good thanks thank you
very much yeah how you doing
have you been listen man I'm just a fat
old man ran away but when I even sit
beside such a image I can't when did you
become an old southern colonel but I
know that I'd like to take you for a
walk down to that Creek yonder I was
talking literally when I said
breathtaking and it's very hard to speak
when you go got no breath left
what
all right you got to come back when this
masher isn't here yeah I like this
lineup we got to get our we got to take
this on the road you guys want to go
I'll go on the road together and take
this act around town I don't think I
could survive it I mean right now if you
were to take my post you'd have to
subtract eight okay so scream queens
there's Tuesdays at 9:00 on Fox yes and
look for Kiki's new book out yeah hope
I'm in it we can we can work it out it's
coming out in January and you got to get
me in there fast by January 2017 look
for the Conan his hot chapter keke
palmer thank you so much
[Applause]
you